let's jump into this first story from
timcast.com Casey DeSantis teases
Governor DeSantis presidential campaign
big if true
here's the video they say they call it
Faith because in the face of Darkness
you can see the brighter future let's
just play the video so uh y'all can see
it for yourselves you ready for this
here we go is the audio right make we
got the audio right
[Applause]
you can see that brighter future
of faith that our best days lay ahead of
us
but is it worth the fight
do I have the courage is it worth the
sacrifice
America has been worth it every single
time
text launch to
512345 wait five one two three four five
that's the video and uh I feel like this
is taking a bit of the wind out of their
sales Casey DeSantis also tweeted out
big if true in reference to this story
from Fox News Florida Governor Ronda
Sanders to announce candidacy for
president Wednesday on Twitter sources
so uh we all knew it was coming and
tomorrow Rhonda santis is supposed or
for those that are listening to us later
later today our Rhonda Santos is going
to be doing an interview with Elon Musk
on Twitter and they're going to uh he's
going to announce he is running for the
present for the presidency so we know he
is now I think putting out this story
and putting out that tweet pulled a lot
of the wind out of their sales I can
understand leaking a little bit like
expectation may happen tune in don't
miss the show but tweeting out that
video basically just announced it and I
feel like that's gonna Elon Musk is
gonna have the interview and then what's
gonna end up happening is there's going
to be a good amount of people maybe 20
20 30 a lot of people who have normally
watched the the Twitter space are going
to be like oh I know already they put
that video out it said text launch we
get it we get it so I don't know what do
you guys think a lot of people are
ragging on them already a lot of the
Trump people uh genuinely are upset
about this I'm gonna say it outright I
think that people who are upset at
Rhonda Sanders are scared of him
uh I do think that this is kind of an
example that he needs a better marketing
team no offense guys if you're listening
right now but I agree you just stomped
on your own fire
um you should have let Elon make the
noise for you so that everyone went back
and watched that Elon interview over and
over again and this is like coming off
the heels a couple weeks ago I think you
Tim on Twitter you had some issues with
his marketing team also
where was that yeah they got they got
Megs I tweeted about jazz Jennings and I
was like why are they so mad yeah but no
I think people will still go to go back
to the Elon Musk interview it's still
going to be a big deal I just think this
pulled a little bit of the wind out of
the sales and us talking about it's
pulling more more wind out of it so that
this okay so I'll tell you right now we
originally the the original title of
this was going to be
um Target emergency meeting they're
pulling back this big boycott Bud Light
we're winning and then it's I'm looking
at the news and it's like they basically
announced also okay well there it is
that's the story the announcement video
was shot from underneath him to make him
look large obviously that's bit
manipulative they should have used some
slow motion with a few cuts to give some
action because it was a very slow boring
video that's just more of an artistic
critique look I think this is the
biggest non-surprise ever I do think a
lot of people are going to watch Elon
musk's uh announcement tomorrow night uh
and look the the race is ultimately
going to be Donald Trump versus uh
Rhonda sanus I think it can be healthy
we just got to stay focused on beating
Democrats uh you know a lot of folks
back home pretty confident Donald
Trump's going to win the primary and
they want to see the competition you
know at some level but they also want to
everybody stay focused on beating
Democrats instead of beating each other
up yeah the other the other aspect of is
I'm very glad Ron's running so as
critical as I'm going to be about the
way that they're announcing I I like
more competition I think we need that we
need more Democrats RFK and Biden we
need to see those guys debating we need
to see Trump and DeSantis debating I'm
very happy about it yeah I mean I love
what DeSantis is doing in Florida part
of what concerns me is just how damaging
it can be to any politician's reputation
to go up against Trump and how good he
is at just ripping these people to
shreds it's one of his Iran very strong
talents yeah and you just wonder if Ron
gets in the ring with Trump is this
going to have lasting damage to his
political brand
yeah I think that's the fear for anybody
I mean particularly you know getting
across ways with Donald Trump hard to
avoid because those are the tactics
Donald Trump uses he goes after the
person he doesn't really go after the
argument and it's worked pretty well for
him I guess the hope for a lot of people
is that he can kind of work his message
in a different way because that's I
think the key to appealing to like
Suburban women convincing people that he
really is going to be able to flip
States uh like Arizona and Wisconsin
again and get the win and you know
people are saying oh well that's the
that's the appeal of the Santas we think
Trump Maybe Can't Win well the
competition will prove it and
potentially solidify Trump and if it
doesn't hey who knows where we go what
are your feelings like personally
between these guys and just the
Republican party in general like for
president I mean I I haven't endorsed
anybody in the race so far personally I
love both of them uh you know when I
first came to Congress I mean when you
come in in a special election I came in
in June so it wasn't like everyone else
was coming in I'm like the new kid and
when you come in you you
um have to make a speech and like
literally you go down and you address
from the floor of the house uh all of
your new colleagues and okay it's only
on C-Span but it's kind of a big deal
and so big crowd comes in after you know
take the oath of office and flow through
I make it to the back up where the
freedom caucus and some of the people
that I had gotten to know already were
and this guy comes up to me goes you
know hey I'm Ron DeSantis you're from
Troy Ohio right I go yeah and I didn't
it's like I thought it was neat that he
knew where I was from he goes my wife
Casey's from Troy Ohio so she literally
graduated from the same high school as
my daughter graduated from uh kind of
small world stuff interesting uh her dad
was the optometrist in the Town Square
so I like that as Santa's people I hope
that everything stays friendly I would
be happy if Rhonda Sands was President I
certainly was Happy When Donald Trump
was president and I'm confident he would
do a great job again yeah I'd be happy
if Veronica was President I'd prefer uh
Donald Trump I think Trump's going to go
in get revenge fire a lot of people I
think Rhonda Santos goes in and shakes a
lot of hands I think policy wise Ron is
doing a lot of things that help America
in a lot of ways but I wonder if that's
what we need right now well look one of
the things he did as a governor is I
mean he inspired Governors to be better
than they would have been otherwise in a
lot of States
look yeah well Donald Trump inspired a
lot of Governors to do that and Rhonda
Santa's look oh I would not have had it
backwards yeah yeah Ron DeSantis would
not have won and I think he'll be clear
on that he would not have won without
the support of Donald Trump
but as Governor he did his own thing and
did it really well and I think it's
inspiring he's a pretty young guy he's
younger than me I think at some point
he's got the potential to be president
but just like you said Sheamus hopefully
if he doesn't get derailed right yeah
well and you mentioned that he couldn't
have won without Trump's endorsement
that's certainly true the first time he
won he just barely squeaked past but we
have to acknowledge that his next
Victory after that was an absolute
Landslide I mean he turned Florida from
vague really purple to dark red he
crushed it there I think he's done a lot
of good I definitely hear everyone's
concerns I mean if this was a question
between DeSantis being president and
Trump being president I'm a happy man
right yeah then there's a question of
who's most likely to defeat the
Democrats in a national election
that's tough yeah I see a lot of people
saying that uh I I've look I've seen the
polls the polls are very favorable
favorable for Donald Trump but I've also
talked to people out just in the streets
in the cities and the general
conversation is they groan when it comes
Donald Trump the moderates and the
independence I mean to say and uh the
sentiment seems to be elected sandus is
a normal guy this is why I think Elon
Musk is doing this interview with him
because Elon Musk said something like I
just want a normal person to be
president or something like that so I
think Elon does want Rhonda Santos to
win hmm no whatever that means but what
I was saying before when I said I don't
know if we need that right now in
reference to good policy of course we
always need good policy but I think what
we desperately desperately read
desperate desperately need right now
there we go I got it is a purging of the
corruption well exactly and this is
something that it's important to really
pay attention to which is throughout the
entire Trump presidency his rhetoric and
his tactics and the way he interacted
with the elite was much more criticized
by media than were his policies just as
you mentioned we're will go after people
and not necessarily policies and though
I'm sure you'd agree with me he does go
after policy often as well
the media was almost always attacking
Trump as an individual sometimes they'd
go after his appointments that was
pretty popular sometimes they'd go after
a policy or they'd say we're upset that
he pulled out of the Paris Accord but
often it was the the rhetoric in this
speech was damaging or the way he speaks
about people in the media makes them
feel unsafe or whatever they were
bloviating about and so that's part of
why I think those are the things we
should love about Trump because those
are the things that terrify our enemies
he's called Rosie O'Donnell a fat pig
which is like not a good thing to say
right but
um I think overall and I'm not saying
that there are not valid critiques to
make of Donald Trump's rhetoric but what
I am saying is there were times where he
was so unbelievably on the money in a
way that I have never seen another
politician be capable of right when he
said I'm I'm the president for for
Pittsburgh and not Paris I mean 100
nailed it nailed it you look at the
drain the swamp rhetoric you know what
you're saying Tim look that was a phrase
that look it it sums up if that meant a
lot in 2016 if it meant something in
2022 post Durham report when you look at
this drain the swamp is going to be the
theme you look at Elon Musk I mean he
bought a crime scene the question is
what are we going to do about it that's
a very good way of putting it he bought
a crime scene he did all the evidences
there that they were suppressing
information that they were I mean if a
foreign government had done what Twitter
did we'd be calling it an act of War 100
and kudos to Thomas Massey who coined
the they bought a crime scene phrase
okay okay good for him the problem with
draining the swamp is that I think that
the swap is clogged I don't think I
don't think it can be drained without
some serious uh that's why I'm saying
drumming but he tried last time and he
just he just but it's basically stood
there and looked at it there's a
difference between a first and a second
term and I think Trump underestimated
the swamp and I think he comes into a
second term and he just says there's
nothing I've got the snake there's
nothing holding him back anymore I think
that schedule F story was real yeah I
think I think Rhonda Sanders gets in and
says look guys let's let's shake hands
and figure something out together and
then it's just schedule Edge you think
realistically that because my my fear
and thought is that if any president
went in and they're like all right
schedule F I'm firing all the heads of
all the agencies the alphabets all these
administrators you're fired the CIA
would just have him killed like that and
then no one would get fired that's my
thought you mean like JFK yeah exactly I
don't I don't I don't I don't I don't
think so I think they did that back in
the day but I think you when you look at
Julian Assange you can see their tactics
have changed so when you look at Trump's
first presence presidency what do they
do they accuse him of being a Soviet spy
now now that now they're trying to
accuse him of rape yeah and so you're
seeing Democrats now using the E Gene
Carroll story as definitive confirmation
even though there's no evidence of
anything it's it's insane so character
assassination is the tactic and they're
trying to make it illegal for him to run
I mean that's I haven't been following
the story the last couple weeks but
what's been going on in that venue have
you like since they were well they're
they're they're going after him in New
York for criminal charges which we know
about he's apparently going to be facing
new criminal charges in March of next
year they're already talking about that
Federal level you've got the classified
documents George you've got elected
election interference they're just gonna
throw whatever they can at them they're
going to use every procedural
manipulation to try and stop him I'm not
sure they're going to be able to pull it
off
that's it and then
if something bad happens to Trump I
think this country just implodes if you
look at the hardcore Trump supporter
um you know indicting Trump or
convicting Trump isn't really going to
change their support but if you look at
the people that are already kind of on
the fence you know there's almost no one
that doesn't have an opinion at Donald
Trump I mean he's got 100 Name ID and
99.9 people have a pretty fixed opinion
of them so how does he move those people
and I think they just keep building
negative building negative building
negative and that is the tactic like you
were saying and it's been working you
know and so the question is but you look
in Ohio you know Donald Trump his
message was built for Ohio everything
about it I mean I got to be on Air Force
One ahead of the election with them and
showing stuff uh people did like a
three-hour long tractor parade you know
and he was just blown away it's like who
would think these people like a
billionaire from New York and like they
don't just like you they love you like
no one made this happen it wasn't a
campaign event it was just organic and
that kind of support is still there
amongst the base but the question is
when you go into places like you know
the suburbs you know places like uh
Pennsylvania places like Wisconsin can
you flip Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan
again can you still hold Arizona I mean
that's going to be the decider in this
election
man I'm I I feel like uh oh hey hi good
to see you uh
um I I'm so concerned with votes being
tallied on machines in private with
proprietary software code but but did
you hear Arizona's Banning electronic
voting machines oh based no that's
baseball
yeah they uh they said unless they're
manufactured here in the US and the
source code is public it's got it I'll
free the code yeah I do dude I gave you
a shout out earlier when I was reading
the news and they said they can use them
as long as the source code is public and
it's made in the United States I was
like public Source public code well
there it is now we should we should
actively create one of those and use it
in Arizona instead of just revert yeah
yeah and uh Dominion said that they were
going to be going out of business
because of reputational damage and I'm
like
if you have the option Dominion of
either going out of business or building
your voting machines here in the United
States with open source code why would
you not choose the latter wow just be
like oh I guess we go out of business
especially if you just got a 700 million
dollar plus-up yeah yeah so they didn't
say I guess it was an interview and the
guy didn't say explicitly that's it
we're done for he said based on the
damage we think we're headed towards the
drain that reputational damage is is too
much they're afraid of the name
recognition they need to change their
name just like uh Blackwater did I think
I think Monsanto got bought by Bayer
because they didn't like the name is
that coming for Bud Light
every every state should do what Arizona
did and say look we don't care about you
want you want out of this one I'll tell
you it's really simple the left is
complaining about the right because you
know Kerry lake is following his
lawsuits and they say you won't get over
2020 I'm like all right all right
everybody slow down here's an idea no
more foreign built voting machines
it doesn't even matter like I don't
understand the argument against it it's
like what we got to spend money to get
upgrade upgraded voting machines for
election security everybody should be in
favor of that we make them here in
America that's American jobs good
working class jobs we do open source
codes that people have a right to see
the code why would any Democrat disagree
with that it's a requirement for all of
our defense Contracting so why wouldn't
it be for our voting system have you
looked much into the blockchain for
voting uh security you know blockchain
really offers a lot of look it's it's
immutable it's distributed Ledger it's a
more secure way it's I mean frankly the
most secure Computing system is truly uh
available with the proof of work kind of
architecture
um but a lot of people don't understand
it uh for one and two uh it really isn't
scalable yet but I think you're going to
start seeing blockchain voting for as
for shares so I think when you can do uh
votes for things like shares that way uh
you will eventually see blockchain as an
immutable record of what happened and
you can audit it it's fully audible
everyone could download a node if you
want to track the election in your state
download the node you see everything all
the code is there it would be a great
way to run an election thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time